so we'll when I watch this movie I
screened it everybody in the room was
sniffling from crying
I gotta execute cry when you watch the
movie definitely definitely
my father was was sick so during the
time of my preparation for collateral
Beauty he was you know dealing with the
you know his mortality and you know the
the experience and the creation and the
depth of understanding of that loss
I hope creates a beautiful authenticity
for for audience members who beauty
collateral Beauty means to find that
light at the end of the tunnel you know
we don't really see Howard talk
throughout pretty much the whole movie
but once he starts to communicate and
engage with the with the abstractions we
start seeing that he starts opening
himself up he started opening opening up
his heart to to go through that pain to
find that joy in life I was surprised by
what got me in the sense that you know
you you know what's coming in ways
others don't but there was there were
funny little touches in it that caught
me maybe some of the smaller moments
that I wasn't expecting yeah it's it's
very affecting I'm not sure what your
personality would have to be to totally
duck emotion on this phone and so the
character Howard the lead character he
waits to three abstractions love time
and death yeah if you choose one to
write to what would you write I would
write to love and I would want lessons
in how to be just stay in a state of
love for as long as possible and for as
much of the day as possible I think
that's where we need to be the state we
need to be in but it's so hard to hold
on to like somebody upsets us in it
suddenly like you go to rage or you get
anger or you're upset or whatever and
it's so hard to like click back into
that loving state that's the great
unknown that's that's that's the one
most people are interested in a letter
from the other side of so maybe I go
with that would you ask what's going on
the lead character in this film rights
to three abstractions love death and
time if you could write a letter to your
younger self when you just began acting
what would you say in that letter I
would say
be gracious be kind be aware that
everybody else is doing a job like you
and you are no more important than they
are
it's something I've learnt I mean I'm
not saying I was a jerk you know when I
was younger but the sooner you learn it
the better it's the family connection to
everything
[Music]
you